oh yes Democrats have for a long time
then prepared to govern ready to lead
and determined to make the American
people proud we have been working on our
issues for a long time to think in a big
way you know you hear the liquor you
hear the campaign debates and people
talk about specifics of policy and the
rest here in Congress we've been talking
about a bigger vision a vision that that
goes back to our founders they were
again entrepreneurial thinkers big
thinkers about the future so if we're
talking about the creation of jobs we
talk about innovation they were
entrepreneurs our founders they believed
in public-private partnerships and we in
that spirit do as well it's absolutely
essential if our economy is going to
grow that the private sector is in the
lead on that next we talk about the
health the issue of health care
everybody talks about access to health
care Democrats talk about access to what
Democrats in the Congress are talking
about a bigger vision not just health
care but a healthier America it's about
diet not diabetes it's about prevention
not amputation it's about thinking about
how to raise our children and their
lifestyle and how we prevent them from
falling victim to dispositions because
of bad habits early on it's about again
major investments in science in terms of
basic biomedical research and technology
to make sure that every person in
America has the customized personalized
care he or she needs when we talk about
building infrastructure of America back
to our founders Thomas Jefferson he had
a plan for building the infrastructure
Erie Canal
berlin road into the Louisiana Purchase
and following the Lewis and Clark
expedition he heat heat asked for that
to his secretary of the Treasury 100
years later in honor of the Centennial
Theodore Roosevelt another great leader
of our country a Republican he is as
part of his infrastructure agenda he
established the National Park Service
100 years later in that tradition
building infrastructure in a green way
takes us to preserving our planet again
science and technology and engineering
all of it coming together to preserve
the planet for reasons that relate to
our security our economy our
environmental health and our moral
responsibility I say it in poor words
science science science and science it's
absolutely essential that we have these
investments in health sciences and hard
sciences so that we can think in a big
way about how how we go forward so we're
ready oh we again we have the foundation
we have the vision we have the knowledge
we have the judgment with a plan and I
believe that the American people are
with us and when they learn more about
our agenda more will be with us and we
have the leadership that when we have a
Democratic president yes we'll be able
to lead govern make people proud and
will do so in a way that lives up to the
highest ethical standard that is
fiscally responsible no new deficit
spending and will do so with the most
civility and bipartisanship that's our
responsibility to our founders to the
American people and to our future
you